[Music]
but here's the deal
if incentives help us beat this virus
i believe we should use them we all
benefit
if we can get more people vaccinated
president biden asking all americans to
get vaccinated saying 90 million
americans who are
eligible for the shot have yet to begin
the process
well brian the president is calling on
states and communities to offer those
100 dollars to
every person who gets the vaccine and
it's a plan already in the works here in
clark county the i-team's david charns
in studio with the details and david the
big question
what about the hundreds of thousands
already vaxxed
yeah so the answer is no this proposal
would give a hundred dollars to anybody
who begins the process to get vaccinated
but keep in mind
we're talking very early stages here
commissioner tick sega bloom says the
county could budget 10 million dollars
from the hundreds of millions it
received in federal coronavirus relief
that's a hundred thousand people in
clark county getting the vaccine each
getting a hundred bucks
you heard the president calling on
communities to implement these
incentives
commissioner sega bloom tells me as more
and more private companies require
vaccines or proof of a negative test
just makes sense the reality is
employers are going to start saying
we want you to either be vaccinated or
get tested
on your own dime every week or twice a
week
so i mean there are going to be some
financial penalties involved whereas if
we give you this
100 then you make money as opposed to
have to pay money
now the commission will be talking about
this coming up on tuesday
new tonight when you join us here at six
o'clock where kovitt is spreading right
now we're going to show you which zip
codes are seeing the most cases
in this most recent spike i'm david
charns 8 news now